And the answer here is yes; player 1 can always win this game here that I gave you.
And 1 strategy for player 1 to do this, for example,
is to move this piece over here to here.
Now it's player 2's turn, and player 1 is now threatening to win in the next move
by moving this piece here to this piece here.
Now, player 2 could try and block this vertex here,
but player 2 can only do this with this piece here.
If player 2 were to move his or her piece over here,
then player 1, in the next move could, however, move this piece here to that vertex.
So no matter what player 2 does, player 1 will win in the next move
by either moving this piece here to that vertex,
or being able to move this piece here to that vertex.
Player 2 could also use this piece here to block this vertex down here,
but that would still keep this 1 here free,
and player 2 also cannot reach any of the vertices that would let player 2 win.
So for this initial configuration here, player 1 can always force a win.
Now, if you figured out that quiz yourself, you should be very, very proud of yourself.
Asking this question: "Can player 1 force a win?"
for a given instance of Roadblock on a graph with end vertices
is provably harder than any problem in NP.
Which means that this problem requires exponential time to solve,
even if P were equal to NP.
So even if you showed this, or had a nondeterministic gram available
to solve this problem, you would still require exponential time.
And that is why Roadblock is 1 example for a game,
or asking a question about a game, that is harder to solve than anything in NP.